i found you ghost
the leader of raven's rock
you might have heard of it
[Music]
if you are fast enough you may be able
to save innocence from a horrible death
the timer has begun
hurry
save the others
and try not to die
according to russian folklore there are
actually two different types of
werewolves
one is known as the waiyukullak
this type of werewolf is the result of
an individual seriously angering the
devil and in turn is punished and has
been transformed into a werewolf
however the waiyukulak were most often
not considered to be evil or even
dangerous
in fact after they had been turned they
would usually just return to their
village in search of love and affection
from friends and family
unfortunately for them they were also
cursed to spend their days moving from
house to house and village to village as
they are unable to stay in one place for
long
forced to rely on the kindness of others
to provide them with food
which brings me on to the other type of
werewolf which is known as the bodak
because in contrast to the wayukolak the
bodak has chosen to become a werewolf
transformed by a ritual that involves
venturing into the forest and stabbing
the trunk of a tree with a copper knife
the individual then recites an
incantation and in turn becomes a
werewolf
most importantly the outcome of this
werewolf is very distinctive
they maintain all of their human mental
capabilities and also become incredibly
strong savage cunning and intelligent
they are intensely loyal to their own
kind along with those they have deemed
to be a part of their pack
[Music]
unofficially named bodak the details and
existence of these russian soldiers
appears to be highly confidential
according to the russian defense
ministry there is no official record of
them
this implies that they are a highly
covet unit that operates under the
foreign russian military intelligence
agency
the bodak were first discovered by the
united states government after receiving
intel from a confidential source who was
working within the russian federal
security service
the intel talked of an advanced special
operations unit
this was later confirmed after
intercepting a communication between a
general and a colonel from a military
base located in the russian town of
kandalaksha
it was discovered that this general was
in charge of a group called the special
training unit 500
the special training unit 500 or bodak
is composed of personnel who are senior
and experienced swetness troops
they are equipped with the absolute
latest in cutting edge weapons and
tactical operations gear including
communications and battlefield
management systems
with superior training and extensive
combat experience even over those who
are already considered to be the
pinnacle of their game
this unit is the best of the best that
russia has to offer
at this stage it's completely unknown
how the bodak fit in with the russian
chain of command however it's likely
that only presidential authority can
have this unit deployed much like the
ghost teams
in fact until more information is
uncovered comparing the bodaks to the
ghost is probably the easiest way of
understanding their position
where covert ops teams of spitnaz could
be compared to the us delta force
ghost teams are composed of elite delta
force members as are the bodak with
spitness
the ghosts first encountered the bodak
in 2024
team hunter had been sent in to rescue a
georgian special forces unit who went to
investigate the launch of a nuclear
missile by russian ultranationalist
group ravens
rock the ghosts find that only one of
them is still alive and has been
captured by the russians
while attempting to rescue him the
ghosts were ambushed by a spetness unit
who are using technology and weapons far
superior to what they would usually be
equipped with
they would later find out that these
troops were part of the elite bodak unit
and have now betrayed their government
siding with raven's rock
raven's rock have gone to stage a coup
taking control of the majority of russia
the ghost team then heads into northern
russia to support loyalist russian
forces in their fight against the ravens
rock army
after successfully achieving this the
ghosts rescue a loyalist russian general
who is the head of the resistance
with his support they find the russian
president who is being held in prison
and return him to moscow where they
would eliminate a raven's rock general
shortly afterwards they would encounter
more bodak and ravens rock forces
however the ghosts were successful in
overthrowing them killing the raven's
rock leadership effectively putting an
end to the crisis
following this mission the ghosts were
made aware of bodak operatives who had
stolen large amounts of classified data
the ghosts hunted down the operatives
in turn killing four of the bodak
officers in charge
despite being taken down by the ghosts a
year later there were sightings of
raven's rock operatives on aurora
the ghosts investigate and find not only
raven's rock but also a number of bodak
units that have made their way onto the
island
sentinel leader trey stone had made a
deal with the group they were planning
to carry out a massive bioweapon attack
on the united states
the ghosts were successful in locating
their operations on aurora killing key
members of both ravens rock and the
bodak teams
after the events of operation greenstone
where the ghost would go on to take down
walker and the bulk of his wolves
nomad in his team lee veroa having now
completed their mission
however months later the island has
quickly become a strategic place for
powerful countries who are looking to
get a hold of the technology contained
within
seeing this threat the cia aims to ease
global tensions by giving power on the
island to a neutral force the outcasts
thus turning a roar into an autonomous
country
one of the groups who have invaded
aurora are the bodak who have now teamed
up with the remaining sentinel and
wolves
the bodak hold large territories and
multiple locations of interest across
the island
and it's up to the ghosts to put a stop
to their operations once again
one thing that doesn't quite make sense
to me with operation motherland is where
did all of these bodak come from
from what we can see in the trailer
there is an absolute heap of them
bringing a huge number of vehicles
the ghosts have taken them down a number
of times now
one of these was only 12 months ago
during a major operation where the group
that was supporting raven's rock was
attempting to take over one of the
global superpowers
i would have thought this mission would
have been of greater concern than this
little group of islands in the pacific
so where were all these troops that are
now evading eroa when their generals
needed them
also this seems to be a hell of a lot of
them not just for a spec ops team but a
super elite spec ops team
i don't know maybe some of this will be
addressed on release
as a side note it's interesting how
similar they are to the wolves
like i said earlier the spit snares are
essentially russia's version of delta
force
the ghosts are made up of elite
experienced delta force members
the bodak are made up of elite
experienced spitness
the wolves are ghosts who have betrayed
the us government
the bodak would go on to betray the
russian government
in fact if you wanted to look into it
further there seems to be a reoccurring
theme across a number of hostile
factions under the ubisoft banner
anyway i hope you enjoyed this video and
i'll catch you in the next one cheers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]